ten years ago I Gregory Sadler have the
greatest ambition a philosopher can have
and through my iron will I will see it
done you intend to find the meaning of
life you intend to understand the thing
in itself you intend to ground math and
pure logic no none of those Petty
matters I intend to read Georg William
Friedrich hagel's the phenomenology of
spirit from cover to cover impossible it
can't be done
seven years ago
five years ago
three years ago
quick break to watch some football
present day so what will you do now I
have finished my work it is done
well it is the kind of book that rewards
rereading so perhaps I'll start again at
the beginning what are you serious